do you fantasize about because I'm gonna
read the laundry list of projects you're
involved and in a way I'm gonna prove
that you think you are now Tony Stark
you'd be gone full out Tarzan are me and
you yeah I think you think you're Tony
Stark yes because they need you go to
Amazon and there was some event yes Yuri
Mars the remarks convention you and you
walk in there and you start the like
Tony Stark you're introducing a I right
you're now pursuing AI I am artificial
what do you mean by that well I'm when
you when you say you frame it like I'm
pursuing AI somebody there was a bunch
of super smart people at this lunch and
I was prepping to be a keynote speaker
and somebody said you know between
robotics and AI we could probably clean
up the planet in less than a decade if
we could get organized and do it I said
oh my god
what what let's do it let's start a
coalition they're like well hold on now
hold on now everyone said Robert don't
don't don't
take this on are you known for that for
starting things and then not completing
them or are you someone who follows
through in this instance I knew that if
I felt this impetus because I was like
why is it that everyone talks a good
game but when it really comes down to
stepping out of all but I shouldn't have
said that and well can you qualify that
and I was like the guy you said it is an
actual genius what could be more
important than you Tony Stark Robert
Downey jr. who's now become Tony Stark
forming a company and saving the planet
right I mean I love this concept it's a
good concept and that's pretty much what
it is right now this saving the world
thing they tie it so cavil you get the
plastic out of the ocean yes how do we
do it let's do it how do we well first
of all that massive floating island in
the middle of Pacific it in and of
itself isn't hurting harming or doing
anything it's just an eyesore it is the
micro plastics and mas that need to be
addressed and you think maybe through
artificial intelligence we can clean
this up a is part of it but what it
really is is as per usual it's breaking
down the lack of communication the turf
wars the self-interest and all that
stuff it's kind of like trying to teach
an old dog new tricks because if you
don't it's gonna die so you form the
company
that is we have it we have a coalition
called the footprint Coalition will be
launching that in April and then they'll
probably be some media associated with
it well do some podcast and stuff yes
look at you look at me so now you don't
have to worry Howard iron man is on it
yeah yeah become iron it's like remember
Bela Lugosi when they buried him in his
Dracula costume
now you pinche Tony Stark but I like it